ya hemos trabajado en muchísimos vídeos
con las transformaciones de lawrence y
lo que quiero hacer ahora digamos en vez
de pensar en las coordenadas x prima y 7
prima como hemos estado trabajando en
vídeos anteriores digamos en términos de
x y de 7 de verdad como podemos ver aquí
ahora lo que quiero hacer es analizar
cómo es el cambio en la coordenada x
prima y el cambio en sete prima verdad
ahora en términos del cambio en x y el
cambio en 7 muy bien entonces veremos
que esto sólo va a requerir de nosotros
que hagamos algunas manipulaciones
algebraicas muy sencillas muy bien
entonces vamos a comenzar viendo cómo es
el cambio en x prima jr y el cambio en x
prima lo único que es es la x prima
final menos la x prima inicial verdad
entonces lo único que tenemos que hacer
es sustituir estos valores de x prima
final e inicial en términos de x final y
x inicial
este final y siete inicial- verdad
entonces vamos a ver qué pasa primero
con este término muy bien este término
será gamma que multiplica a x final
menos beta 7 final verdad simplemente
fue poner con finales y ahora restamos x
y prima x prima verdad que sería x prima
inicial vamos a hacer esto con color
rosa muy bien vamos a hacerlo con rosa y
qué es lo que tendremos sería gamma que
multiplica a x inicial menos beta 7
inicial muy bien entonces ahí lo tenemos
y ahora lo primero que vamos a hacer es
factorizar gamma así que vamos a ponerlo
con el color original de nuestra gama
verdad factor izamos gamma y que es lo
que tenemos bueno tenemos aquí
x final verdad podríamos poner aquí x
final y también podríamos poner un menos
equis inicial verdad si nosotros digamos
distribuimos este signo menos verdad
entonces vamos a poner aquí menos equis
inicial y luego que otra cosa podemos
poner bueno podemos poner este término
de aquí verdad que sería menos beta 7
final verdad y ahora podemos distribuir
este signo menos con este término que
tenemos aquí y entonces tendremos más
beta 7 inicial muy bien entonces ahora
cerramos el paréntesis y esto qué es lo
que nos queda nos queda gamma que
multiplica
esto que es x efe que es x final - x
inicial es justamente el cambio en x
verdad x final - x inicial es el cambio
en x y ahora en estos términos amarillos
podemos factorizar menos beta si factor
izamos menos beta que multiplica
multiplica se te final menos
inicial verdad ahí tenemos beta factor
izado y la ventaja es que ahora tenemos
aquí en este paréntesis el cambio en 7
muy bien entonces esto será simplemente
gamma que multiplica al cambio en x
menos beta menos beta por el cambio
ct bien por el cambio en 7 entonces este
cambio en 7 también podría escribirse
como c veces el cambio en t es
equivalente verdad ahora no tenemos de
esta expresión verdad que hemos obtenido
esta expresión para el cambio en x prima
es exactamente la misma transformación
del lawrence pero para las variables
cambio en x y cambio en 7 de verdad y de
hecho tú puedes demostrar por tu propia
cuenta que tendremos el resultado
análogo para el cambio en 7 prime
entonces ya que sería igual el cambio en
7 prima también podríamos verlo como c
veces el cambio entre prima será igual a
digamos al resultado análogo verdad será
gamma que multiplica al cambio en 7
- beta menos beta por el cambio
x muy bien por el cambio en xy entonces
como podríamos ver es exactamente el
mismo argumento que hemos usado en el
caso anterior verdad para calcular el
cambio en 7 prima simplemente lo
escribimos como ct prima final menos
siete prima inicial sustituimos con
estas expresiones verdad hacemos alguna
manipulación algebraica y obtenemos lo
que he puesto justamente aquí verdad y
la razón por la que he hecho todo esto
es porque ahora podemos pensar en
términos del cambio en las coordenadas
lo que nos va a permitir pensar cómo
serían las velocidades en los distintos
marcos de referencia